hello
i know many people are curious about who
i am and how i approach my work
okay off the table okay this is a class
for those who want to understand my
leadership style and then understand the
experiences that have helped me
become an effective leader love that
page triple triple thumbs up
you need someone who can push you that
isn't pulling you back
i do not believe in micromanaging it's
important to empower those that are
working with you because
you are nothing nothing without a good
team
it's really really important to surround
yourself with a team whose opinions that
you trust
who are not in any way frightened of
disagreeing with you
and you have to listen
possibly the most important meeting that
we have is the one that we have when we
all come back from the shows
i would love for you to come with us to
one of these fashion meetings
there is always a time when you know you
have to break the rules
this cover was a deeply controversial
cover but kim and kanye were part of the
conversation of the day
and for vogue not to recognize that
would have been a big misstep
you are leading you are not following
and that's a very important
lesson to always keep in your mind
[Music]
you are driven by your heart you're
driven by your talent
and you're driven by your instinct and
you if you start to
question and look what people are doing
to the left of you or to the right of
you
you are going to lose that clarity of
thought
listen to the information but in the end
it has to come from who you are
own your decisions and own who you are
but without
apology i'm anna winter
and this is my masterclass
you